Our houses were demolished.
There was no building left.
Whole cities were flattened.
Everything disappeared.
We can feed our souls here,
but no one knows
how we're going to live much
It's freezing,
and we will be frozen to death here.
If we sit inside the tent,
we will freeze.
Those are the stories
that we are hearing from
some of the survivors
about a week
after the 7.8 magnitude earthquake
leveled parts of Syria and Turkey,
leaving so many people in despair
with major questions
now about what to do.
More than 36,000 people have died
and the toll is continuing
to rise
as aid
and rescue efforts are underway here.
A nine year
old boy
was pulled from the ruins
of a collapsed building on Sunday.
This father and daughter
were rescued out of the rubble,
still alive in Turkey.
All of this is coming as criticism
and anger is building
towards the government
and President Erdogan
of their handling of the crisis.
Even Erdogan
acknowledging that the government's
initial response was slow.
CNN's Sara
Sidner is live in southern Turkey.
Sara, I know we were talking earlier
the rescue efforts
were very much underway.
The recovery efforts
of all of this debris
that you're seeing behind the scenes.
Is even hard to breathe
because there's so much smoke in the air.
What are you hearing from people
You know,
the moment
that we
got on the ground,
just within moments
of stopping and getting out of a car,
we were approached
by a woman
who was begging us to help her
find her husband.
The sorrow is so palpable here.
That is what you notice first.
Then you see the amount of destruction
and it really is
hard to get your mind around it.
Oh,
yes, sure.
Yes, you
do, because it's
the 38 year old Code Red Coachbuilder
desperately pleads
with volunteer rescuers
to search for her husband, Kadir.
He's buried,
she says, in their corner apartment,
which is somewhere under this rubble
They try to console her,
but this mother of twins wants action,
not words.
This gives you this picture
now to get older. You are.
There is nobody out there.
It's been six days.
I'm waiting here with my twins
standing in the cold.
She says she's been asking anyone
who will listen to dig her husband out.
But for six days,
she says officials
kept telling her
they needed permission
from the government
to start on her building.
I'm still here.
I want my husband back,
even if he's not alive.
She may have accepted his
death, but can't go on
without seeing her husband's body
removed from this hellscape
My life, my blood, my everything.
My best friend in life.
He left me with my twins here alone.
While she waits for the realities
of her husband's death here in this area
where you see enormous piles of rubble.
These are different buildings,
but you can't really distinguish them
because there's just so much destruction.
There have been signs of life.
A child was found here alive
after a week in the rubble.
Nurses comfort the girl who they think is
three or four years old.
She's dehydrated and in shock, but alive
This is the moment she was rescued.
Her exhausted little body
pulled from under
the seemingly endless mountains of rubble
and her time
mother was still motionless and
she was rushed to the makeshift hospital
set up in the parking
lot of the actual hospital
that was evacuated after the earthquake
hit Candy.
When she first arrived as a mother,
I felt that she was like my own daughter.
This nurse says
she's cracking up the staff.
She's talking.
When we walked in,
the toddler had managed
to make the nurses laugh.
Relieved she could talk a bit.
What is it that she said that made
you all laugh?
She made all the nurses laugh.
I mean,
Mama,
I meant the word that made all the nurses
laugh was Mama.
And I'm hungry.
I want to eat something
What does that do to your heart?
When she said Mama cried.
I felt a great pulse in my heart,
she says.
No one knew her name.
And when they asked, she said, Dada.
It turns out this
toddler does not speak Turkish.
She speaks Arabic.
Rescuers later tell us she's Syrian.
Here we go.
Sara, I know
you've been reporting on here.
Do we know anything else
about the little girl
You know,
we went to the area
where they pulled her out
and there was no one left.
What we do know is
perhaps what's going to happen
is when she is fully treated,
she is going to find out
that they have not yet
been able to find
either of her parents
at this point in time.
We are now in the eighth day.
They do not think that
they have survived.
So this little girl may indeed
become an orphan
after all that she has been through.
Caitlin
And just the thought
that she's not the only one.
There are so many other children
living through that same thing.
Sara Sidner,
you're live in southern Turkey.
Thank you for being there this morning.